it is official tomorrow marks six months
to the day
that joe biden was sworn into office and
unsurprisingly
well i can start out by saying it's been
an unmitigated disaster on multiple
fronts
ever since joe biden let's see the guy
that cheated his way through law school
caught plagiarizing multiple speeches as
a politician
of course he coasted on obama's tales as
vice president
but you can't fake your way through
being the president of the united states
except the media mob covers for you and
you're in the media mob protection
program
but now sadly we are all suffering the
consequences
so tonight the six month anniversary of
joe
let's break down issue by issue and let
us grade biden's performance shall we
first up let's look at the hostile actor
vladimir putin from the hostile regime
the country known as russia
on the campaign trail joe biden falsely
accused president trump
of being too soft on russia even
referring to donald trump as putin's
puppet
and biden's tough talk was apparently
reserved just for donald trump
well his first six months in office it
was joe biden
that bent over backwards to please
vladimir
it's biden who is really putin's puppet
likely
compromise due to the three and a half
million that his son
zero experience hunter got for his
company from the russian oligarch former
first lady
of moscow imagine if that was a trump
kid we now know that some of that money
went to joe himself
and get this after russian hackers
disrupted america's
most important oil and gas pipeline
and other hacks that took place biden
rewards russia
by lifting all u.s sanctions granting a
waiver
on the nordstream 2 pipeline project
from russia into
germany our western european allies all
while firing
high paying career jobs for those
american workers on the keystone xl
pipeline right here in the u.s
next after another russia hack targeted
our food supply and our meat supply
biden again rewarded putin with a
one-on-one summit in europe
the so-called summit produced zero
concessions from vladimir putin
so biden's grade will start here for
handling
russia and putin yeah that would be a
big fat
f no one in modern history has been
weaker on russia
than joe biden now keep in mind russia
along with china
they're now supplying iran with weaponry
the number one state sponsor terror and
they're providing supplies to conduct
their proxy wars and their terror
campaign all around the world
that didn't stop joe biden from green
lighting and pressuring
south korea to hand over seven billion
dollars in frozen
assets to the iranian muellers now this
is iran
we now know is once again enriching
uranium under joe's watch
at an accelerated rate it's clearly on
track to develop a nuclear weapon
that's happening on joe's watch now
remember this is the same iranian regime
that has
stated has a stated goal of wiping
israel and the united states
off the face of the planet and the same
iran the chance death to israel death to
america and burns both our flags
the same iranian regime that just tried
to kidnap right here in our country
a journalist in new york city but
instead of punishing iran
joe is appeasing the muellers in iran
even lifting sanctions
in spite of these open hostilities it
looks like the iranian muellers
own joe biden so joe gets another
f as iran is now more they're now
more emboldened than ever before and
sadly biden's performance surrounding
china
well that might be even worse biden is
refusing to hold china accountable in
any way
for the death destruction and damage of
covert 19. he remains pretty much silent
as china
is threatening our ally taiwan
and saying oh yeah there's going to be
reunification in other words
we're taking over he can't be bothered
to address
last week china their hostile maneuvers
in the south china sea
has no response to china's public
threats
they are making threats against the
united states and our ally japan
and our military bases and not a word
from joe
no response whatsoever and just this
week chinese hackers
they were responsible for another major
cyber attack against the united states
but joe biden's response is once again
non-existent
oh that's right the bidens aren't just
compromised by russia and ukraine and
kazakhstan
that's right zero experience hunter got
a 1.5 billion dollar deal with the bank
of china
and 100 000 shopping spree for his
family from a chinese national
for these reasons let's give joe another
well-deserved
f domestically biden is also performing
extraordinarily poorly
inflation is at its highest rate in 20
years everything you buy gas food
good services you're paying more every
single day for every item
he gets an f on inflation and this is a
massive tax on everyone
but it especially hurts those people
that live paycheck to paycheck
the lower up middle class america
they're getting hurt the most
it impacts everything you buy it impacts
heating and cooling your homes it
impacts filling your
car with gasoline 1.25 more per gallon
for gas
thanks to joe and so another well we'll
say f for joe
on energy and once again we're energy
independent
and trump made us energy independent for
the first time in 75 years we all
benefited financially and for national
security reasons
and by the way joe biden's attempt to
ram through the green new deal under the
guise of
human infrastructure i thought
infrastructure was roads and bridges and
tunnels
no human infrastructure is the new green
deal
except with a fancier name while also
raising corporate taxes
that's right as he raises and proposes
his
corporate tax increase that means costs
will continue to go even further
beyond inflation beyond the higher
course cost
of energy being used to get products
to shelves in the stores because yeah
those trucks that bring them there
they're all paying a fortune more
corporations i've said many times they
don't pay taxes
they either cut salaries cut jobs and
then they pass the rest on the we
the people the consumers so he gets a
big fat f on the economy as well
and meanwhile at our southern border a
major crisis is now ongoing
we have open borders we got kids in the
middle of a pandemic in overcrowded
cages
laws are not enforced they are
facilitating law breaking and they're
aiding and abetting in the process
and joe lifted all of president trump's
successful border protections
he ended all trump's policies and those
policies were
working and then he tasked well one of
washington's most incompetent
politicians
with solving the crisis that would be
his vice president kamala harris
it's so bad we're going to give joe
biden three apps for his handling
on the border which brings us to an
important question
why did joe biden put kamala harris in
charge of the southern border
why is kamala harris holding regular
meetings with the secretary of state
why is she routinely the one making and
taking one-on-one calls with world
leaders
and hosting them in washington d.c is
there something wrong with joe biden
now keep in mind president trump
conducted interviews held impromptu
press conferences
almost every day at times with very few
exceptions
joe biden hasn't done an interview with
the american press in 68 days
that's the on top of the only one that
he gave previously
he averages less than one public event
every workday
he goes into hiding on every weekend his
public facing
time amounts to around maybe three hours
a week that's it and during his short
scripted events
he's usually reading from a teleprompter
quite poorly
or from a note card and still getting
confused he almost never takes questions
because he claims he's going to get in
trouble they'll yell at him his staff
will be mad
and still during the rare public
appearances joe biden struggles mightily
and he appears to be very blunt this is
objective
he appears to be getting worse almost by
the day
take a look you decide this is enough
vaccine
to fully vaccinate 300 americans
by end of the summer the beginning of
the fall
but we want to make look that's i want
to repeat
it'll be enough to fully vaccinate 300
americans
to beat this pandemic 300 million
americans
i have a card i carry a card with me
every day with the total number of
folks who have been affected by the uh
as of uh yesterday
i want to thank the the
former general i keep calling in general
my
my the guy who runs that outfit over
there
i'm proud to nominate david chipman
to serve as the director of the aft
david knows
aft well visit
vaccines.com.gov vaccines.com
or text to your text your zip code to
438829
but uh there's you know there to be
you know beginning uh this effort uh for
2021 is uh i think we've learned a few
lessons we hold the true self-evident
that all men and women we haven't lived
up to completely but we've always
widened the arc of commitment
this job this jobs
the jobs that are going to be created
here
i'll be in better shape to talk to you
about it
i'll tell you what they sent me one one
thousand two one thousand
i can't even in good conscience joke
about this anymore because it's not
funny
this isn't good now if we can see this
and by the way 57
of the american people see it and we're
probably
one of the few shows in the country that
actually shows it
that's how viral this is now becoming
people see
that yeah they don't really think he's
in charge america's enemies
also see this this is deadly serious
and uh they're looking to exploit the
united states at every turn and they're
doing it
right before our eyes joe biden is a
cognitive mess his radical socialist
staff
that whoever's in charge they're
promoting horrific policies oh of the
squad and bernie sanders
his vice president frankly seems
clueless also
his administration is failing on so many
fronts
matter of fact what has he done well six
months in it's not going well
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else